here we are
hello hello little Tamra wait we're
concerned that little Tamra's oh this is
like half the behind the scenes of our
anything about it's just us always
looking forgets I gotta find the right
outfit perfect suit perfect see I mean
do we want to try this well it's still
for me what about just like a big
sweatshirt what about just like a big
sweatshirt oh I see say that say those a
maybe I like to find some possible oh no
no you're in that is a yeah gotta be Jim
you can only be janitor Frank Frazetta
painting is he still around
no he died oh okay it's a pretty reason
about this Oh super red super likes it
it's like you might take that home
like I gotsta know try it no there's
always this oh wait this isn't Brazil on
it
yeah it's kind of tight too oh yeah you
know it's like cuz I'm thinking like
traditional little kids clothes I'm also
the kids clothes are pretty tight and
stuff for that thing I like but we want
to hide an adult looking like a little
kid - yeah it has to be bigger and baggy
and stuff from see it's almost just in
case that doesn't work I guess we have
this sweatshirt if that doesn't work
well if you wear something over at
around looks cool it does that way for
something else yeah try that now we
might just do the sweatshirt
it's always so tricky
oh they're family yeah if weekend's it's
got one more color in it yeah and maybe
we do like share something we can do
with that's broken to us I never really
pay attention looks like what do even
little kids wear it was like I guess
just t-shirts and like once again oh
wait do we solve that one see outfit the
big red thing yeah yeah maybe we do that
cuz I think we've we did that once for a
jurassica see oh it's definitely closer
you look like you look like a little kid
a drink girlhood yeah I think I'm
getting whimsy I think myself like you
know now looking like the onesie way and
then like wait why are we doing the ones
I can't remember that red thing but I
just looked cool I just can't remember
yeah she's got a lot of stylish all the
women's clothes here are probably
Joanna's yeah you know Joanna has a
sense of style
yeah like any sure that's like really
awesome is usually gins any light female
thing is user Joanna's anything is like
what's the problem
where's the just I know where's the
fight oh so here one is e10 getting one
they're really cute they're so
comfortable okay oh if you know what
kigurumi czar like the they're basically
onesies well maybe you'll even mine does
look kind of cute ish yeah I'll try go
ahead boy I'll see
it's getting awful wet oh and the pipe
but yeah a lot of people are suspecting
that this is just ask that guy back in
disguise
hey bite I might just dis money cuz it's
like more more I do this character he's
like so evil and mean I'm like yeah
maybe this is just how he kicks revolves
you know like some sir a story with him
or something
it is like yes yes I am just doing a
spectra turns it's like supposed to be
the traditional father and it just
somehow does these terrible things and
stuff but it's just like yes count ask
the guy had the pipe and everything and
he always have this sage advice
well quote-unquote sage advice yeah yeah
just make sense to do that now he's a
father that is tara feature well this is
the first one because the the character
of Tamra did last week what was so good
that now we're gonna have it that he's
married to her and these are just gonna
be the worst parents ever but I think
we're always gonna probably switch out
the kids
yeah they don't really just like never
have the same yeah they keep cycling out
for some reason over there very a child
you're a proper child Rachel the boa
with the evil Eva because it's just what
you just look you guys oh that's not
child huh it's like they always end up
getting turn into like costumes yeah I
don't know actually then it's just gone
I don't know what happened - okay so
where this is gonna be this is gonna be
you complaining in the opening you're
just gonna have your bear you're gonna
be thrown of your face you can shout
whatever you want is like you just go
hey I like Jamie I don't like Bobby
Jannetty tomorrow my ID you can just go
ahead I'm just going to keep going yet I
like hers
totally Tamra all right you ready mm-hmm
and actually I don't like anything mama
gets stuck I want a computer where's my
facebook page whoa TVs the worst I ain't
going outside roof is like today I
journey inside all the time
ah why am i this Barry sucks he's not
even a computer I hated good on this one
just just whine all right buddy I'm
always good on one leg away from
Pharisee so you have to look forward you
see over here just on terra's just
before this baby's crossing like you
show her this court I shot this clinic
just dealing is this all you want to be
like oh yeah isn't it to look after
okay this is Tamra Tamra has it there
Tamra is screaming yeah have you seen
that meme oh yeah yeah what I mean okay
I like to see it but what actually like
is it I know it's always like it's you
you put yourself in it but then what do
you like do or would you just push this
button and then it looks through your
feed and kind of figures out a vagueness
of who you are and post something and
it's like okay and so it like figures
figures you out right I mean actually I
guess they must be kind of correct if
people keep I was doing them yeah
they're big yeah they're a before that
like somebody turned it into a generator
but before that it was just kind of like
a cautionary thing saying if you see
something offensive on the Internet
you know don't react to it just leave it
alone but now it's becoming this yeah
yeah
Julia it's just it's the internet yeah
oh oh and my glass
yeah cuz right you think he had a bigger
glasses right thicker feeling one things
black glasses that they are yeah yeah I
remember they always really reflect and
like the thick glasses through some
reason reflect a lot more than just my
regular glasses
okay so look at script see what Covey
you want CQ mousies and secretive dim so
yes I'm gonna come up ed you junkie
beyond uh carrier so yeah look honey get
what CQ mousies are the secret of NIMH
yeah you a you again you decide I'm
gonna walk out oh that when using super
then so good so serious one get back
we're okay hey honey
no wonder they child is this way alright
uh good start recording good rollin hey
hey honey what CQ o Malley's in the
secret of me wow these really do work my
vision what I thought I don't remember
into that wall hello Jim good okay try
that one ready and action
hey honey want to see kuegel mousies in
the secret of them good okay i like try
one more okay ready and actually hey
honey want CQ well now he said the
secret of did i did that little mouse
key okay siri stop shot ready action
hey honey want to see cute little
mousies in the secret of
this family let's give your spin-off
series yeah yeah be like oh what the
hell's it that Carol Burnett spin-off
wasn't all my family want to call mamas
family
yes I'm like a house that used to be our
mom yeah the fucks like yeah good okay I
see spelled a few CHS yeah
looking really worried
good I'll see if you can uh just one
very slow descent or like yeah like
you're just starting to notice the what
the fuck are you like
okay well if it didn't weaken we thank
you kids up slow wait till you see the
cafe a woman chasing local terkoz okay
and the scene does you're just too cool
cuz that's what the decapitate what is a
fucking he's a long time oh shit that
should be the tagline at the end yeah I
do another 80s films we fiction yeah I'm
gonna do that let's see so yeah so this
one it's like there's already astir
capitated you know how are you a just go
uh you know like you just you kind of
want to scream but yeah chaos alright so
yes there's no dissent you're just
already in that mode and a little bit a
little bit worse Stelling you're so
terrified with fear you want to movie
you want to scream but you just can't
like you won't open your mouth even
wider all you give them just mortified
yeah action ah
good uh first half of that just sort of
keep that and maybe get the eyes a touch
bigger so you don't quite go that Oh
like that but yeah like that that's
really good and okay so yeah your day
you don't need to say anything you're
just gonna be rocking action go which I
know ready and action
yeah you're done with that thing we'll
go ahead get in the crazy mother
well just have ten more this family done
yeah one day we should just like cuz I
like baby of always changing up the kids
just have like one day it's like an
Asian kid hmm might know somebody
circuit now they're just so darn hard to
find well I mean someone I'm acquainted
to you now can get me an agent you get
it he's hit already right
keep them on standby that's probably
offensive I don't know how right oh you
know what I'm talking about
mama Tamra's back Oh God
you play this so well I love this
character it I think all the characters
their place it's so fun and this is so
comfortable it looks comfortable you
just like I love it I work around my
house oh yes just getting off that third
shift straight vodka it's disgust yeah
that's what she would drink before you a
lot guys you sit there on the couch
eating cold hot dogs and jennyline this
is reaching like honey boo boo territory
Jim is like perfect
CD boohoo did not age well
you get it I encountered a green monster
shirt a Tara knows a little kid
purchasable right now Jim oh okay I -
tell me you're going to be up here
Jim you're going to be right here I mean
the first one is we're gonna pretty much
react like you know the kid is right
there and we we turn around
Tammy you say right there's no doubt
about it and I say our daughter is at
one and yeah you just tried to say you
always no doubt about it you start
taking a sweet is it I don't know is it
possible for you to take a sweet while
still have the cigarette hilarious oh oh
yeah yeah you're holding the wrong it
might you like the filter good tasty
shower I don't know smoke both ends
hey oh the bottle uh can you fake just
like you know man I hate your lips just
like let it yeah is what its gonna be is
so we're both gonna be looking over
there why say action we're both gonna
turn around as we're turning around Jim
you're gonna track in on us you want
slow tracking or you want me to kind of
pull it ah she says ik well there's no
doubt about it like as soon as we get to
that patch when you stopped it well
there's no doubt about it
don't I say our daughter is a twat okay
leave behind Jim real quick Marty
halfway oh she's just letting some
pretty hat win it's too much - yeah
there's too much it's a new bottle
you're yeah yeah throw in the other and
we're gonna act like he's over there see
80s movies what's that
where are you looking uh he's supposed
to be right here so like we're actually
right now
close to mine but the magic of film and
then they'll notice Fido here you say
that's what the morning-after pills for
then we look at him uh yeah I think I
like double check I'm pretty sure that's
how it works see well yeah righteous is
with morning-after pills for and then we
just turn and I think we'll look about
right there I think it's responsible
okay you want to go run for real fast
and action
well there's no doubt of that our
daughter is at what this is what the
morning-after tears for it eighties
movies what's that that's a very good
question
okay try everyone ready
and action
well there's no doubt about it our
daughter is at what this is what the
morning-after pill is for you now hey
these movies what's that well there's no
doubt about it
our daughter is at what this is what the
morning-after pill is for you know
eighties movies what's that
nej great town and action
well there's no doubt about it our
daughter is a twat this is what the
morning-after pill is for you now in
these movies what's that yeah I think
just be say we'll do a few reactions
like hey you just and action
well there's no doubt about it our
daughter is a twat this is what the
morning-after pill is for Hades movies
what's that I'm drunk
perplexed
there won't be by just until the
indictment this is going to be a little
bit of it you won't forget I have is
that we're gonna turn around and Tamra's
in though you can see but can't we get
in trouble for showing our kids this I
get we're acting like we're talking to
him but then Malcolm's gonna appear in
front of the camera looking at the
camera no problem as you see right here
laughs let's see up again control Joker
kids this no problem
mosaic is a PG rating but that was back
in the day one actually meant something
nowadays the stains were practically
cheap so you can plead that you've
innocence to your cruelty um there's a
do you have that line down yeah I go
yeah uh I think yeah we can print you a
little bit where we'll be I mean you'll
still be in the same spot yeah
oh he's gonna pop a comment I reckon
yeah we're gonna dance you know looking
at the same spot but then he's gonna pop
up here okay
you shall soon see decision oh my god
my husband's dead and my child's dying
everything is trying to kill me
good even faster oh my god my good good
please oh I know stuff I'll articulate a
touch more club but yeah good speed on
that oh my God my husband's dead and my
child's dying
everything is trying to kill me and my
family's drowning to death ah good
I hid more frantic oh man this is it oh
yeah okay oh my god good is still ran
together a little bit more
oh my god everything you're starting to
kill me good one more the articulations
good just a oh my god
try one more on and my uh child's dying
cool the whole thing yeah I'm opening it
oh my god my husband's dead and my child
is dying good so close just on family
Shani to death I ran to get a little bit
everything else pitch perfect okay I
think I'll try the Kerman
I really am hold down all the way this
this is the beard I'm just gonna leave
it like this yeah so literally a neck
abhi yeah but Kermit's in there he's
watching oh no he's a horny toad oh no
she's great a great joke I guess so
editor like you I think that's very
obvious clearly from my garb
there we go that way I can go cuz the
big thing keeps going up like no so if I
go like that I'm you me bill oh don't
make me take the pig on you live a bear
Oh freaking bear talking to you watching
home on the internet I see you watching
me yeah yeah yeah I knew my sitcom where
did we get that from me ah forget it I
created this cow screaming that's
another thing we see is dollar store
Kermit here that's why we should go with
our starter and it's the dollar store I
know I'm a kid too young he doesn't
think that you know it's not very
flexible yeah but you can do this hmm oh
this completely dislocates his job
sorry
oh man yeah you got the inside oh wow
Jim just anything we take back boys
another whistling yeah well that's uh
let's go shootin yeah this is gonna be
fun
so fatherly oh do you want wieszczyk oh
my god she got to the pain meds again
you can see what going oh my god how she
got to the pen go together okay but you
don't have to make your voice go Lori
yeah just you still screaming actually
come over home did you have a good dear
God punished you got some pain meds
again action Sara our home did you have
a good dear God how did she also hang us
again hey Tamara go ahead just gonna lie
down right there I want to see if I can
actually
you gotta be more kind of like their
sister
the frothing at the mouth photo shoot
where one more model she's like that
more bottles me this is home coming up
my very specific front yeah that's
perfect
today you're conscious you're selling do
you feel frothy I'm pretty frothy right
now good good yeah I'm doing my best
it's exactly for the scene you're
perfectly fatherly concern fucker
without this I was like as I'm putting
us down like and without this coat it's
basically a schmee will dead oh yeah um
Malcolm take a step back that way it's a
good one more step whoa I mean the frame
yeah it's we watch it Wow okay um I
start recording here so you guys you can
water your mouth ready yeah and Jimmy
you don't have to come in
you can already be there it's a bit oh
my god okay just do the last line yeah
okay
decide to use it sure it's you just
wanted a drink of what get a good amount
of water in there - it's not - it's very
fresh waters gonna be hard not to
yeah yeah and be sure to turn and do you
need me to take the packet or any like
okay all right all right ready whenever
you are
all right so she's gonna start fun with
the night drew the line yes okay
oh god honey she's got in the pain meds
again
that was great
again Yeah right in the wig oh it's very
salty oh ah drinking water to that yeah
yeah waters writing wrong dirty rinses
yeah okay dunno yeah okay yeah oh yeah I
know you said the voice all day got this
that's totally tammer totally Tamara
only on Disney oh yeah you got that
grupo wit fit is watching that Disney
Channel there's something a little funny
about like cuz when the Miley Cyrus is
Hannah Montana right yeah so cuz
everybody sing and she's the daughter of
um Billy race yeah Billy Ray Cyrus yeah
and then I was like oh he's raising this
girl right and she's not gonna grow up
crazy or not doing anything like that
and how he's doing right how he's doing
a graded all these stories are coming
out now saying like how she hated that
show and hated not bullying that it's
like that's interesting yeah yeah I mean
it's an amazing I don't want child
actors to fail anything I want them to
not go nuts cuz I know it so easy get
sucked out to their world and it's like
yeah but it's just how they do it right
I'm just like
I'd say it looks like 10 years we'll see
I think she's a hat yeah it'd just every
week I see like you know by Osiris in a
rival with it on the summers I don't
care about is some person seriously yeah
I I always have a theory like they just
meet up these rifles and they're just
like okay so I'm gonna say this and
you're gonna say yeah yeah like shyness
and it again apparently yeah sure LeBouf
how is he yeah he's getting her stuff I
don't know I think it's a publicity
stunt
Scott it's kind of like what walking
Phoenix did yeah with uh yeah I'm stupid
I get the feeling he's just like
Macaulay Culkin now I got all the money
of the ROPS with you do him fuck I uh go
ahead like that yeah sure looks truth
Cameron yeah and what I'll do with uh
you know you're gonna put in you're
going to let it drip and then when I say
go you're
go maybe it's the opposite - physics
yeah just missing that does it for good
yeah here's a wrap oh yeah
such a refreshing thought yeah you know
it's so funny that Jimmy did you get
this costume original here's this the
old houses the old uh the Jack Sparrow
okay yeah cuz in Halloween I had a Jack
Sparrow outfit and uh yeah it was like
years before any of this and like yeah
it's just a funny thing we're still
using that yeah not anymore
cuz it's good saliva means we use it
even more because what stick
you look okay what oh oh yeah right yeah
insert
you